Ariana Grande and Pete Davidson call it
quits
[Music]
according to multiple reports the two
still have love for each other but
things are over romantically the news
comes just one day after the singer was
scheduled to perform at the lets f
cancer hero's gala in Los Angeles but
canceled last minute her manager Scooter
Braun gave a speech at the event and
addressed her absence
saying she needs this time to heal
Lexie's Lehren through love the 25 year
old singer and the 24 year old SNL star
got engaged
back in May after just weeks of dating P
Davidson
thanks for existing the couple couldn't
help but publicly gush over their
relationship and just be crying like out
of happiness literally lately I was on
FaceTime last night crying are you okay
you know like yeah and during Saturday
Night Live's season 44 premiere Pete's
cast wasted no time teasing him over
their romance
what's the prenup situation well
obviously I wanted one you know so god
forbid god forbid we split up and she
takes half my sneakers no look I'm
totally comfortable being with a
successful woman I think it's dope I
lived at her place you know she pays
like 60 grand for rent and all I have to
do is like stock the fridge yeah but the
engaged bliss came to a halt when
Ariana's ex-boyfriend
Mac Miller suddenly died Ari has shared
her heartache with fans on social media
tweeting can I please have one okay day
just one please et has reached out to
Ariana and Pete's reps for comment
[Music]